اجواء المباراه في استاد المدينه
التعليميه امس فرحه عارمه عربيه مغربيه
حديثنا عن الاجواء كيف كانت بالفوز
المغربي الثمينه التاريخي
ي اهلا سهام واهلا بضيوفك طبعا الى يعني
ساعات الصباح الاولى والدوحه تحتفل
بانتصار تاريخي للمنتخب المغربي همم طبعا
دائما نتحدث عن ما قبل المباراه كان هناك
احتجاج بالالاف الجماهير المغربيه
والجماهير العربيه في محيط الملعب قد تكون
هذه المباراه الاولى التي تشهد هذا التجمع
الكبير من الجماهير يعني حتى طفت اللجنه
المنظمه الاستدعاء عناصر اضافيه
لضبط الوضع في المنطقه المحيطه همم الكل
كان يرغب ان يدخل الى المدرجات والكل كان
لديه فكره كبيره بالمنتخب المغربي اثناء
المباراه يعني كانت همم
همم
الاوضاع مشدوده والاعصاب مشدوده بسبب يعني
وصولها الى الاشواط
الاضافيه ولكن بعد المباراه كان هناك
الاحتفال الكبير وانا كنت داخل مع
الجماهير وشاهدت هذه فرحه المغاربه كانت
لا توصف داخل المدرجات وايضا حتى احتفالات
اللاعبين في منطقه المكزون في اللقاءات
المختلطه بعد المباراه يعني التقيت بمعظم
اللاعبين المنتخب المغربي كانوا سعيدين
همم جدا بهذا الانتصاب وقد يكون يعني همم
نوعا ما تغيرت والطموحات ترتفعت الجميع
يتحدث عن نصف النهائي وانه
سيكون لهم بصمه في همم المباراه المقبله
وس- لن يتنازل عن الوصول الى نصف النهائي
اول منتخب عربي في التاريخ يصل الى نصف
النهائي بعد كسر الرقم في وضع نهائي